jessica how are you
i'm good how are you
i'm good you ladies are going at the
action hard in this movie like really
going for it and so you got to correct
me if i'm wrong but i think like the
mindset
that you have to be in when you're doing
those stunts and that action
choreography is like i'm just going to
do this 125
no matter what happens we're making this
work is that is that accurate
absolutely there's a scene where i run
and jump off this like
crazy building and like land on a barge
ship that's that's going away
and they weren't going to have me do it
and i was like no no i'm going to do it
we're making this movie i'm going to do
it and i said where am i jumping from
they pointed so i said okay take me up
there and then it started going like way
beyond what i thought it was going to be
and i got up there and i was so scared
because i was really high i mean it's
like
like
you don't want to move because you're
afraid the wind will knock you off
and the stunt um coordinator looked at
me and said you know jessica you don't
have to do this because he could see i
was scared and i looked down and i saw
all of the crew
that was the kind of beautiful thing
about our film like the crew was with us
because they knew it was an interesting
thing we were making that you know we
haven't really seen these actresses do
these things
and they were all looking up at me and i
was like nope i'm doing it i'm doing it
yeah
i had to 100 and 150
yeah i'll take that i'll take that over
my estimation so tell me like what is
the percentage of like
um
when you're when you're doing those
things and we see you go like ah like
you're taking a hit
that that particular one when you land
like it looks like it hurts
so how much of it is oh i'm acting this
like i'm selling this
that that really hurt like that was
listen there's no there's no trick it
always hurts
like when you land
i landed on you know i'm supposed to
like kind of land and get hit here you
know like i don't make the jump all the
way
they made me do that over and over again
and i think the one you see is i
literally had the air knocked out of my
lungs like but it's it hurt
but you know
it's all it's it's oh it's awesome i
mean it hurts but so does like climbing
a tree and like falling out of it like
it's i get to do a job where we play all
day and so yeah fine
they're like which take looks like it
hurts the most that's the one take that
one which one actually hurt yeah that's
the one we're using you see that
let's get that yeah that's real
so what was your favorite part about
having all these amazing women working
together on this like super cool female
driven action flick
well everything you just said that was
my favorite part is having all these
women work together we're all the owners
of the film which cut is kind of a
radical thing for the industry it's not
normal to have the actresses in your
film be the owners of the film and be
the bosses
and uh that's the most exciting part
fantastic all right well listen it's
been such a pleasure chatting with you i
hope you're all healed up
from um i mean it's been a while right
so
bruce congratulations on
heal
congratulations on the film uh thanks
again for the time all the best
you